[Music]
yeah young people today in particular
but even adults don't have a tolerance
for boredom at all you know there's some
research looking at how how our
attention spans have changed across time
there's some evidence that they've
shrunk by about 33 percent since the you
2001 reason for that is because we
interact with devices so much of the
time and they don't demand anything of
you
they are deliverers they bring things to
you you don't need an attention span if
you're reading a book if you have a
lapse in attention for even a couple of
minutes you know you'll get to the end
of the page you realize that you haven't
really been paying attention for the
last half a page that's a problem and
you have to return back to where you
were
that requires wills and directed
attention that's just not true of smart
phones they are constantly competing for
our attention every app every social
media platform pretty much everything
you encounter on a smartphone is
designed to give you what you need they
are competing for you instead of you're
competing for whatever else is going on
in the world and what that means is you
don't need to have much of an attention
span and we've seen this in a lot of
different respect even beyond smart
phones of themselves the way we interact
with email for example that when we get
an email it in the office place in the
workplace it takes us on average about
six seconds to check that email and
every time you check an email you spend
25 minutes getting back to the zone of
engagement you were in before you check
the email and so what's happening here
is we just don't have much attention for
the things that we're doing because
they're constantly distracted we're
pulled away to do things like check
emails quickly refresh a Twitter feed
and Instagram feed and so on and as a
result we we really don't need an
attention span we don't need to be as
engaged as we used to and we can still
get through get by in the world I think
we have a lot to be worried about with
respect to the evolution of tech and the
way it engages us we are far more
engaged with tech today than we were 10
years ago and when we look back 10 years
from now I think we're going to look at
Facebook Instagram Twitter as relics and
as primitive relics to be totally honest
I think the degree of engagement will
have with things like virtual reality
tech and virtual reality platforms will
far exceed anything
you see now you know if I'm sitting with
you at a table and we're having a
conversation and there's a phone upside
down on the table next to us just for
the presence of that phone the
connection we form between us will be
diminished and if the phone can do that
turned upside down because of all the
things that it implies that there's a
whole world out there
imagine when at any moment in time you
have to choose between the real world
with all its messiness with all its
complexity with all its imperfections
and this perfect virtual world when
virtual reality tech is is really
advanced and you can basically go
anywhere at any time to speak to
whomever you like it's going to be
really hard to resist the desire to
leave the real world the here and now
the world that's social and and stop
yourself from always retreating to that
virtual world so I do think there's a
big concern I also think it's a concern
from the business perspective that some
businesses make money for every moment
of attention they can grab and they are
trying to basically weaponize whatever
content they put out so that it's harder
and harder for us to resist a perfect
example of this is clickbait on for
example facebook clickbait is something
that's relatively new it didn't really
exist ten years ago and there are a
couple of techniques that clickbait
purveyors have developed over the years
the sorts of headlines they use are
almost impossible to resist they hit a
whole lot of psychological notes that we
can't not respond to they basically open
a loop they open a cliffhanger and you
have to know at the end of the story is
so you click on that button the other
thing that they do is they give you
these pictures that are kind of half
filled so the thumbnail picture doesn't
spell out the whole issue so say they
say you won't believe what this person
did next they'll show you the person
with a surprised expression on his or
her face but you won't be able to see
the rest of the image you have to click
on the image to go to the next page then
you'll get there and it'll be a
slideshow with 17 different slides each
click providing some income to the
company that's releasing it so I think
you know that's more sophisticated than
what we saw five years ago and we're
only going to continue in that direction
it's hard to predict what in ten years
we'll be competing with but certainly
there'll be a lot of competition for our
attention and it'll probably be quite
successful at luring us away from the
here and now I think about our current
time as being added
bottom of a very steep long tall Hill
and we're all moving up this hill and at
the moment we think of ourselves as very
advanced there's this illusion known as
the end of history illusion it's the
idea that where we are right now feels
incredibly advanced no matter where we
are in the tech world no matter where we
are in the evolution of tech I think of
Twitter and Instagram and Facebook is
pretty advanced but in ten years we're
not going to feel that way
in 20 years we're certainly not going to
feel that way we're going to look at the
first platforms social media platforms
as as as relics as curiosities and I
think what's really going to change in
the next few years if you talk to
experts in the virtual reality industry
is that they say between four and five
years from now everyone will own virtual
reality goggles in the same way as we
now all pretty much own smartphones and
once you have access to those goggles at
any moment in time you could leave this
this real imperfect world to go to a
perfect virtual world it's really hard
to see why you would resist that at any
moment in time
I mean if humans are basically
constantly roaming the earth trying to
be as happy as possible hoovering up
well being it seems almost rational that
you'll leave the here and now for the
well being that you could acquire by
leaving and going to that virtual world
so I think that's a pretty serious
concern I think it's a concern because
the social world the real social world
can only exist and encourage us to
thrive when when we continue to be a
part of it if we leave it for long
periods of time I don't know if this has
ever happened to you but if you're
unwell for a few days in your home in
bed when you return to the social world
there's a sort of awkwardness to the
first communications you have that's how
humans are we basically need to exercise
that social muscle across time if we
don't do that if it withers away if we
leave for the virtual world for enough
time there's a pretty good chance that
the way we communicate as a species will
change and I'm especially concerned
about that for kids so there are certain
critical periods in child development
where where kids basically acquire the
social skills that they'll take through
their lives and what they need to do is
they need a lot of feedback pretty rapid
high fidelity feedback if I'm a child
and I take a toy from another child I
need to see what that does to that other
child I need to see his face scrunch up
I need to see and be upset I need to see
him lash out I need to see that really
far
so I learned that's not the right way to
do things but if I'm interacting mainly
through screens I don't get that rapid
feedback and so I never really honed the
skills that I'm going to need when I
deal with people face to face in the
real world and I think that's a big
concern because if you take the whole
screen generation on mass the kids who
are born today I think a lot of them
might may not hone those skills the way
we have in the past so when it comes to
being in a workplace to being real
people forming romantic relationships
and forming friendships I could imagine
that being quite difficult for them in a
way that just came naturally to us when
we existed in a different world as kids
in a world that was largely face-to-face
it's really hard to say whether
unplugging in the long run will be
beneficial whether there'll be some sort
of competitive advantage to not being
engrossed in the tech world I think we
already see some advantages in some
spheres if you if you aren't buried in
your phone if you aren't buried in games
you have more time to do other things
that I think make you successful you
have more time to hone your social
skills you have more time to do useful
work you have more time to form deep
meaningful relationships with other
people I think all of that helps you to
get ahead at the same time being engaged
with tech to some extent is necessary in
this world you need it for travel you
need it to be a member of the workplace
you needed to communicate I think
disengaging completely is not the answer
I think the skill in the long run will
be striking the right balance a lot of
people use the language of
environmentalism the idea that we need
to form a sustainable relationship with
tech and I think the people who managed
to do that over time are the ones who
will have that competitive advantage
they'll be plugged in at the right times
but unplugged at the times when it's
more beneficial to have face-to-face
relationships and interactions I don't
know what that will look like now
already today many of us have plugged in
for the eight hours when we're at work
and then for three additional hours in
front of our screens our phones and then
for some of us additional hours in front
of the TV that's a lot of time that's 12
13 hours during during the day when
we're awake
that doesn't leave a lot of time to do
things like exercise in great engaging
with nature talking to people
face-to-face being creative and
thoughtful reading books and so on so I
think we're leaving a lot of things
behind by being overly engaged with tech
we shouldn't disengage completely I
think the skill over the next
number of years in two decades we'll be
learning how to manage our relationship
with tech in a sustainable way and the
people who do that best I think in the
long run will be the most successful
people and the happiest people
[Music]